Speaker 1: We've been covering the growing
civil war, so to speak, between the
anti-Trump and pro-Trump Republican Party, but the
anti-Trump so-called anti-Trump Republican Party
is often people who were never into Trump. We
are now seeing something different as a result
of Donald Trump making really mild milquetoast,
uncontroversial statements about the vaccines are
pretty good at keeping you out of the hospital
for COVID. A bunch of actual former Trumpists
have turned on Donald Trump, and some are even
burning MAGA hats. I'm going to play a clip for
you here. A former Arizona Republican
Senate candidate. What was this guy's
name? I don't even remember this guy's name.
We're Daniel McCarthy. Yes, Daniel McCarthy.
He has completely turned on. Donald Trump is
challenging Trump to a debate at the Trump
rally scheduled for next Saturday. Calls Trump,
quote a little bitch and then uses a flamethrower
to burn his own MAGA hat. This is great. This
is great. And I'll tell you why. In a moment,
let's take a look at the video. Let's listen.
Speaker 2: Hey, Donald Trump, this is Daniel
McCarthy in Arizona. The world is waking up
to your massive grift. Please stop with the
smoke and mirrors with these audits. Stop with
your fundraising. Stop. Establishment candidate
endorsements stop pushing this gene therapy.
Speaker 1: Now I have to stop there. YouTube
has a policy where it's not enough that my
audience knows I support and accept the science on
vaccines. Every time such statements are made like
the vaccines or gene therapies, I have to rebut it
every time to be in compliance with YouTube. This
is what's going on. So I want to remind you guys,
we have extensively debunked the notion that the
vaccines are quote gene therapies. They are gene
based vaccines, but they are not gene therapies
that change your genes. OK, I just have to import.
I have to do that every time. I'm sorry.
Speaker 2: Source. I hear you're coming
to Florence, Arizona, for another one of
your do nothing rah rah session rallies.
Well, I have an offer for you. I will give $1
million to the charity of your choice. Wow. If you
take 30 minutes of your stage time on January 15th
and debate me or answer my questions even in front
of your crowd, think about all the things that
you've done that you've got you've not been held
accountable for. You ushered in medical tyranny.
Speaker 1: That's not true. Donald Trump
did not usher in any medical tyranny.
Speaker 2: You exploded. Our national debt.
Speaker 1: That's true. He
did explode the national debt.
Speaker 2: You relinquished our
sovereignty with the USMCA trade deal.
Speaker 1: That's untrue. USMCA, very similar
to NAFTA, quite uncontroversial. Certainly
did not give up any sovereignty.
Speaker 2: You pass more gun laws
than Obama did with big snakes that
Speaker 1: I don't even know about.
I'm not even sure about that one.
Speaker 2: You warned about election fraud.
But yet you did nothing to prevent it. Even after
my team months in advance warned you after we
were stolen from in the Senate primary.
Speaker 1: That's just crazy. Talk that
one's hard. That one. There's so many elements
to that one. It's hard to even refute.
Speaker 2: You gave up on therapeutics
and you push an experimental gene therapy.
Speaker 1: And again, the vaccine
is not an experimental gene therapy.
Speaker 2: People are literally dying because of
their trust in you. You know, that's interesting.
Speaker 1: People are dying because of their trust
in you. There are people dying because they
believed based on Trump that they shouldn't
get the vaccine. That's not actually
what Trump said. It's true people are
dying because of their trust in Trump, but not
for the reason that McCarthy is saying that
that's kind of a complicated one thanks to
Speaker 2: the lockdowns, and you surround
yourself with swamp creatures for four years.
Speaker 1: He did surround himself with swamp
creatures. Trump did not enact any lockdowns.
Speaker 2: The Jan. six protesters, it came
down to the Capitol. You set them up. Those
people are being treated worse than dogs now.
Speaker 1: They so set up suggests it was.
I mean, Trump just encouraged them to do
what they did. It wasn't really a setup.
Speaker 2: And these are your most loyal
supporters. Trump, you failed America. Yes, you're
the most deceptive president in American history.
Speaker 1: That's true.
Speaker 2: That's true. Trust me, there's
been a lot of cycles before I posted the terms and
conditions of my $1 million offer to my website w
WW Dot Demand Daniel Morcombe. I look forward to
seeing you on January 15th, although I know you
won't do it because you're a little bitch, right?
Speaker 1: And so now he's getting out of the
truck and he's going to flame throw his
own MAGA hat so the maggots are revolting.
Unidentified: And there it is. Well.
Speaker 2:
And then he stomps it out.
Speaker 1: And then he
drives over it with his truck.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Well, Trump won't
ever talk to me because he knows he can't because
of his family's name would be tarnished forever.
Speaker 1: OK, so obviously, this guy
is completely out of his mind, I mean,
completely cuckoo for cocoa puffs. But the
fact that now even Trumpists are turning
on Trump is very interesting. Tomorrow we are
going to have a report about Stephanie Grisham.
Very briefly, the press secretary for Trump,
she says there's a group of 15 Republicans
getting together to try to preemptively
neuter Trump from ever running in 2024.
So there is a very interesting counter
Trump movement, even within Trumpism.
We're going to talk about it. You can see the
clip. If you were listening to the segment,
you can see the clip of this Daniel McCarthy guy
flame throwing the MAGA hat on our Instagram,
which is The David Pakman Show on Instagram. You
can also find me on Instagram at David Pakman.